I think people find it a controversial and emotional issue...
...because they see media representations...
...of Madonna coming back with a child in a very short space of time.
They think that this is exploiting the children...
...and they see Madonna as being able to buy a child.
Globalization has a direct impact on international adoption.
I think it has a positive impact in that...
...we now have a worldwide community of people...
...who are able to communicate with each other about international adoption.
The negative side is that there is another community of people...
...who could exploit individual children...
...and could be involved in trafficking of children.
We need international regulations to make sure that doesn't happen.
Quantitative information gives a broad overview...
...and looks at international adoption from a statistical point of view.
Qualitative information focuses down on individuals in that...
...research study that are actually at a receiving end.
My interest in research is very much around qualitative research...
...and about looking at structural macro issues...
...and how they impact on individual users and carers.
I think the important thing about qualitative interviews...
...and qualitative research generally,...
...is that it gives meaning to wider policy debate.
People who have been on the receiving end of services...
...should be able to have a say about the services that they've received.